hey everyone I'm Dan Belcher and I'm a
product manager on the Google cloud
platform team at Google we spend a lot
of time thinking about how we can make
operations easier whether you're running
at Google scale or you're a new startup
looking to launch your first application
last month we announced the beta release
of Google Cloud monitoring which is our
effort to make monitoring easier in the
cloud in this session we'll give you a
quick overview of cloud monitoring and
its capabilities Google Cloud monitoring
gives you insight to keep your
application fast and available for
end-users the cloud monitoring console
gives you an at a glance view into the
overall health of your application
including your app engine modules groups
of resources such as compute engine VMs
or cloud sequel instances endpoint
checks which measure uptime of your
internet facing resources active
incidents or alerts KPIs or recent
changes and events within your
application with no configuration cloud
monitoring provides you with rich
dashboards and charts that you can use
to identify bottlenecks or issues with
key metrics you can also configure
alerts so that you're notified when
issues occur the system supports a
number of different communication
methods including email pager Duty SMS
HipChat campfire and more cloud
monitoring also includes rich support
for popular open source packages such as
Cassandra my sequel engine X and others
for instance you can use the monitoring
plug-in for engine X to gain access to a
variety of engine X metrics finally you
can tailor the monitoring experience to
your own needs with a few clicks you can
create custom dashboards that include
metrics from different components of
your system
and you can access advanced charting
tools to investigate issues cloud
monitoring is available to all Google
cloud platform users in beta you can
access cloud monitoring from any of your
projects by clicking on the monitoring
link in the left-hand menu and then
clicking dashboards and alerts cloud
monitoring is an important part of how
we're making operations easy at Google
you can learn more about cloud
monitoring today by signing up for the
beta or accessing the monitoring
documentation from cloud.google.com
slash monitoring